[Music]
in say one submitted by socks and
sandals haha that's David David hmm I
got a buddy like that too I'm like how
does your wife [ __ ] you sandals wrong
they said it might be just a person's
name a family name that's crazy dude
his wife's a good one an Alabama judge
has ruled that teachers have the right
to sleep with their students University
because I immediately went to high
school Mike that's [ __ ] weird it
should be hot teachers have the right to
super yes hot teachers I agree I didn't
dream about having sex with my teacher
when I was a freshman but he was like a
really old guy and it wasn't like I
wanted to have sex with him it wasn't a
fad it was just a nightmare my dream we
had sex and he was really old like
really old like a tease
like probably close to retirement like
in my head he seemed like he was in his
eighties because I was so young yeah
yeah okay but it was so hard to like be
in class after that and that was like
during the first week of school so it
was just like uh you know when you have
like a sex dream about someone yeah I
think he should have lost a job for that
[ __ ] but he not really but my name looks
like I got raped by my own mines yeah he
raped you what if he knew some voodoo
[ __ ] any inception in your head and he
didn't she's real did you ever think
maybe he had the same dream yeah like
sometimes that happens when I have it
like a contact with them I tried not to
I read somewhere that supposedly people
that you dream of they're also dream of
you well that would be so awesome so
it's like a video game where we're all
signing in and having a land party
yeah and we're having the same adventure
that's what the human experience is
hello Elon Musk
yeah the simulator reality we're in a
dream right now right I'm on it's just a
long one that I just cannot wake up from
yeah oh yeah wake up from it any time
you wanted to but oh like a suicide not
inside of the is isn't that fascinating
though that the idea that there's all
the universal laws that we're aware of
exist because it's all computer program
so like like there's height in length
and dimensions because it's fake mm-hmm
it's like laws within a face but with my
mind please it's like why can't we go
the speed of light we can't go faster
the speed of light because everything
will slow the [ __ ] down right oh if we
get the password code we can yeah we get
the cheat code get the game Judy nish
well we haven't figured that one out yet
so anyway this Alabama Alabama judge
he's horny maybe he's just trying to
promote more teachers he teaches on the
side oh dude he got so many fist bumps
on the way to his car so many dudes with
nose elbow Jackie the elbow pads on
their jackets Lee George Jackson my man
yeah so this judge he dismissed charges
from a former high school teacher named
Carrie 44 years old she was accused of
sleeping with two students aged 17 and
18 that's her wrath he also dismiss
charges against David who is 27 years
old a former aide at a different school
and he was accused of having sex with
his 17 year old and so in this state the
age of consent is 16 so it's legal to
have sex and it for an adult has sex
with someone else
yeah with a minor that's 16 and over
what about conflict the [ __ ]
interest in being a place of power
think maybe it should be against school
rules but not illegal like I don't know
if you should be a criminal from that
right but then like as if the law says
it's all right why would the school
override the law like no I mean like my
universe even the school that we went to
you you can't have a relationship with
your teacher in the same class yeah cuz
then that's like against the classroom
like how some places you can't like date
within the workplace like you can't
yeah it's company policy yeah yeah but
yeah I can see how that works it's kind
of like yo I'll suck your dick if you
give me an A right yeah but then after
class it's like I was using you teacher
or the other way around where if you
want an a suck my dick
yeah I was using you student yeah it
could be either way but it's the best
kind of porn though they gotta wait they
have to flirt during class and wait
until like they they leave that class
and then they have a relationship hmm so
what's the ruling so the lawyers and
love these two teachers that were
getting accused they were arguing that
Alabama law which was passed back in
2010 violates teachers equal protection
rights guaranteed under the Fourteenth
Amendment because it treats educators
differently than under that law than any
other citizen so just because they
what's so funny they don't know you like
holding it I'm thinking about where JK
party and his favorite porn is really
talk about know if you got a real estate
lady she's like hey locked up the price
see that's another [ __ ] brawl yeah
that's a problem the problem because I
guess the minors buying a house animal
so then of prosecutors are saying that
because teachers have special
disciplinary and authoritative powers
sexual relations with students is in
here
we course sorry there's a thing that
that law is designed to protect students
and its own courses that's the reason
why that loves it so I wouldn't stop me
protecting their [ __ ] up all the time
the teachers need protect you from your
students no do you not man at this piano
teacher that was kind of hot and this
guy would like always try to get with
her like no thank you know that stuff
and I was just like come on man in my
mind I'm like of course she's not gonna
get with her even though I was thinking
you're right though she is pretty hot I
was like Alice I was hating I was how
old were you guys uh we were like what
20 or 19 and then a piano teacher that's
fine right yeah taking piano at college
oh okay I don't know why I was a music
major so yeah I was thinking you in high
school you were just jealous
Oh jealous yeah I was like I wanted to
flirt yeah I've been you know yeah
so he ruled that Alabama law that was
barring teachers from having sexual
relations with their teachers he ruled
that unconstitutional so then now what's
gonna happen is that this whole thing is
gonna go into the Alabama criminal court
of appeals to see whether or not that
loves me mystic or not I love that
teachers [ __ ] the students is
unconstitutional
getting in trouble for [ __ ] their
cities unconstitutional I love that
sentence it's so great he's like not his
own constitutional guess cause news
United States of America I love that
[ __ ] dude like Thomas Jefferson was like
I love the idea that there are a bunch
of teachers in the courtroom and well
the teachers in the courtroom
and they're all like trying to hold back
the tears but
I never thought I'd see this day for so
many years I have to hide my lust and
love for my studio behind a heart in the
dark
yeah like I'm trying to [ __ ] the dark
[Laughter]
like an American should be yeah yeah I
like that the judge too is getting hate
from the community like there's a bunch
of parents whose kids [ __ ] the yeah
teachers that are like egging the guys
[ __ ] lawn and like weaving weird
signs in his house and stuff is
threatening and weirdly and stuff dang
that's funny dude they're like they're
gonna be the new targeted like minority
group oh yeah teachers that are in love
with students the voting bloc no no to
that he dismissed they were facing 20
years in prison jeez that's crazy
20 years for making somebody's day yeah
yeah if the state law was 18 and over
cuz in a statutory rape but if in that
state it's 16 and over then it's then
it's legal in their state it's asteroid
rapes [ __ ] can be silly sometimes it's
like she's 17 and a half and it's like
you're gonna wait for 20 years like man
it was 18 that's against the
Constitution artists in silliness like
an old man who [ __ ] kids just got out
of jail yeah he's sitting in the back of
the coral breeze like yeah yeah I guess
it should be different should be
different for educators because
around kids yeah yeah but I wouldn't
think that it would be that many years
for someone else
20 years seems like a lot that don't go
away does rule that free ball jerk it is
legal out of the Constitution that
states like Creek a saturn-like you know
I just love all this shit's gonna silly
world I hope you guys enjoy this video
for more please subscribe to our channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]